also ich würde sagen es können ruhig
alle in den film rein gehen weil man
soll sich ja auch mal einsetzen dürfen
und nicht immer nur ein horrorfilm
ich betrachte mich als einen menschen im
exil aber es gibt dass sich eine person
die ich da sind mit großem ernst
verfahren würden sie sich fühlen zu
gehen das ist doch mal was man hört geht
es im emmental sowieso nicht so gut
es ist ein bisschen wie wenn man sich so
ein transporter streamen oder sowas an
kunden nur andersrum
das heißt wenn man sich diese dinge
anguckt soll es ja mit popcorn schmeißen
und adrenalin schauer kriegen und hier
sonst halt gerührt sein das ist ein
bisschen wie in 80ern gab es diesen
schrecklichen film kamen von carlos
saura wo dann alle die rausgehen
flamenco tanzen wollten und so weil das
schon mal mit der leidenschaft und dem
mord und so und ich fürchte dass jetzt
tatsächlich so ein paar malen nach
zahlen mehr verkauft werden nach diesem
fall wenn man über etwas einen film
macht das tatsächlich passiert ist und
worüber ist also quellen gibt wie zum
beispiel ich lese mir meine biografie
durch oder ich schaue mir irgendwie was
dokumentarisches an
oder jemand an den bildern vorbei läuft
oder so und ich das aber zu einer
geschichte aufbrezeln will dann muss ich
eine geschichte haben geschichte die
unser freund schnabel hier in diesem
film hat ist die geschichte der mann ist
so wahnsinnig geniale sieht was das lied
sonst keiner trainerstab wie sieht es
leider auch nicht denn anstelle dessen
das zu sehen was da in die besonders war
sieht er einfach diese postkarten motive
aber so als tableaus wie was das heißt
er nimmt diese dinge die jeder von
postkarten und aus studentenwohnungen
als poster und so kennt und filmt sie
dann so richtig runter das heißt der
findet jemand der die schule so macht
wie der die schule gemalt hat und er
findet er die schuhe runter und dann ist
es aber natürlich nicht mehr erstaunlich
das waren doch diese schuhe anders
gesehen hat als andere leute sehen weil
sie sehen halt aus die schuhe aus denen
also das ist alles nicht so richtig
durchdacht aber dafür ganz schlecht
inszeniert danke dass ich ging ja den
sie da hat halt diese ganze stars drin
sowie das adrenalin kino auch seine
stars hat nur was da megan fox und bruce
willis und sonst willst ist hier halt
aus geäußerte plötzlich gut sein soll so
damals mittel sind ja irgendwie
einfacher spielen oder das gefühl dass
er möchte eigentlich gerne dabei sein
aber okay ich das gefühl dass dabei
wir haben davor übrigens auch aber seien
nicht dabei sein wollen äußert sich als
leit- und passt also flott weil ich
nichts anderes tun können gehört sie mir
ich habe es versucht
der paso linie spielen sollte sich der
komplett aus weil ihm davor aber auch
wie pasolini hier ist er komplett aus
wie vincent van gogh aber auch wie davor
was natürlich irgendwann dazu führen
wird dass wir glauben dass eigentlich
alle leute die irgendwie berühmt waren
irgendwann mal aussehen wie wir dem
davor was uns dann aber recht geschieht
was schauen wir was ich doofen filme an
der film heißt returnity skate auf
deutsch wie vincent van gogh eternity es
geht damit man auch weiß um wen es gehen
tut
und eigentlich müsste das auf deutsch so
was heißen wie der lange anlauf zur
längsten aller weilen
aber es heißt dann wohl doch an der
schwelle zur ewigkeit fühlt sich aber
auch so an wenn man das angucken muss
ich wollte den anderen nahe bringen was
ich sehe jetzt denke ich nur noch
eine beziehung zur ewigkeit nach